hello there welcome to this episode of
the slow mo guys in this video we're
doing a lovely scientific experiment
where we're going to make our own little
plasma cutter using pencil lead for
batteries and some aluminium foil they
spell aluminium wrong okay so the way
this works you connect the batteries in
series
we're gonna connect
one side to the oil meat other side
pencil that like this and record this on
the phantom flex two and a half thousand
frames a second macro lens so we should
go out to see something up close really
nice
you
you
you
I hope you enjoyed that video I quite
liked shooting stuff in macro it's very
fiddly but you get extreme closeup
slow-mo which i think is very cool if
you're a fan of these science
experiments you can add General Electric
to snapchat and if you send them an
emoji on December 10th
they may just send you a little
experiment you can watch thanks for
watching that be sure to follow on
Twitter subscribe to the channel buy a
shirt if you want buy 3 if you want to
be really warm and I'll see you next
time
you